y en eeuu parece que los precios de la
gasolina comienzan a ceder está con
nosotros en el estudio jorge hurtado que
nos va a explicar a qué se debe este
retroceso en los precios jorge muy
buenas noches cuéntenos es bueno
comenzando que la media nacional o el
precio a nivel nacional en ese país bajó
este domingo a 4,5 dólares por galón
mientras un asesor desde el departamento
de estado dijo que espera que esa
tendencia continúe y baje hasta los 4
dólares por galón próximamente el precio
por galón bajó a 453 dólares de este
domingo según la media de la asociación
automovilística estadounidense tanto los
precios del petróleo como los precios en
el surtidor han estado cayendo
rápidamente en las últimas semanas ambos
hot sean quien es asesor principal del
departamento de estado en materia de
seguridad energética dijo que espera que
los precios de la gasolina en eeuu
caigan a los 4 dólares por galón
el asesor dio a entender en una
entrevista a algunos de los príncipes
algunos de los principales productores
de petróleo de medio oriente tienen
capacidad de reserva y podrían en algún
momento aumentar el suministro al
mercado para de alguna forma intentar
bajar los precios de bailén visitó
arabia saudi el viernes con la esperanza
de llegar a un acuerdo sobre la
producción de petróleo para ayudar a
bajar estos precios de la gasolina el
aumento de los precios de la gasolina en
eeuu alcanzaron su nivel más alto en 40
años y está empujando a la inflación al
mismo tiempo que hace caer los índices
de popularidad del presidente
estadounidense lo que se sabe hasta
ahora oficialmente es que biden no
consiguió esta garantía sobre el aumento
de la producción de petróleo a nivel
mundial hablemos ahora de panamá jorge
porque allí continúan las protestas y
también los bloqueos pese a los diálogos
que había entre manifestantes y el
gobierno
bueno las principales bloqueos se
produjeron en la ciudad de panamá pese a
los diálogos que se lograron el día de
ayer se cerraron algunas carreteras este
sindicato junto a otras organizaciones
populares rechazan el acuerdo alcanzado
el domingo entre el gobierno y un frente
de otro gremio para bajar el precio de
los combustibles a cambio de liberar
precisamente las carreteras que
permanecen bloqueadas desde hace semanas
los manifestantes reclaman por el costo
de la gasolina los alimentos y la
medicina pero este sindicato considera
que el acuerdo firmado ayer no incluyó a
todas las organizaciones que convocaron
las protestas en otros puntos había
personas con maletas o haciendo
transbordo para intentar llegar al
aeropuerto ubicado a unos 20 kilómetros
al noreste de la capital panameña hay
otros bloqueos en la vía panamericana
que conecta a panamá con costa rica y
esta es la principal vía de comercio y
transporte de mercancías en ese país
seguimos hablando del alza de los
precios porque te da también está
afectando a varios países de
centroamérica y del caribe cómo está la
situación allí bueno santiago según el
consejo monetario centroamericano el
ritmo inflacionario en mayo se ubicó en
un promedio de 8,19 por ciento anual
según la organización en el escenario
más optimista el indicador podría estar
cerrando en un promedio de 8% a 10%
solamente este año esto por el aumento
de los insumos y materias primas
importadas como el combustible nicaragua
mi país lidera la lista de países con
mayor alza de precios le sigue honduras
y su vecino costa rica- le siguen
también el paso república dominicana el
salvador y guatemala según los analistas
santiago centroamérica está en su pico
más alto de la inflación y la evolución
va a depender de lo que ocurra a nivel
internacional principalmente por el
conflicto entre rusia y ucrania que está
aumentando los precios a nivel global
sobre todo el energía y los combustibles
bueno eso en cuanto a centroamérica y el
caribe pero en suramérica también hay
manifestaciones por el alza de los
precios de los combustibles como esta
panorama ya le tocó ahora a perú que
amaneció con un nuevo paro de transporte
de carga y agricultores que protestan
por el alza de los precios de los
combustibles y los fertilizantes la
asociación de transportistas de perú
afirman que la nueva huelga está
motivada por el supuesto incumplimiento
de los compromisos asumidos por el
gobierno con este gremio esta sería la
tercera protesta que convocan en lo que
va del año los transportistas demandan
la extensión de la exoneración del
impuesto selectivo al consumo de
hidrocarburos hasta el mes de diciembre
algo que según el ministerio de
transporte de comunicaciones de ese país
no es posible según los transportistas
estas medidas sólo benefician a las
grandes empresas y su representante
pidió una nueva reunión con cuatro
ministerios de gobierno y con el
presidente pedro castillo hay novedades
en a por qué se prepara para una posible
recesión según la publicación de
bloomberg la empresa disminuirá el gasto
y la contratación para este próximo año
y busca hacer cuidadoso sobre todo
tiempos de incertidumbre económica según
revelaron fuentes anónimas los cambios
afectarían solamente algunas áreas de la
compañía la empresa fundada por steve
jobs planea varios lanzamientos en los
próximos meses que incluyen su incursión
en la realidad virtual las acciones de
apoyo han caído un 15 por ciento en wall
street en lo que va del año de afectados
principalmente por esta caída
generalizada de las acciones
tecnológicas es todo jorge muchas
gracias punto final de la economía ya
viene el debate